Dois jovens começaram sua jornada no
Bitcoin no ano passado. Um trabalhava 12
horas por dia, olhando gráficos e
perseguindo cada vela verde. Ontem à
noite, uma única armadilha de baleia
limpou toda a sua conta. E o outro
homem? Ele passou a noite com a família,
tomou um café e acordou com um lucro de
5.000.
A diferença não foi sorte, foi o
sistema.
Um estava caçando, o outro estava
defendendo.
A maioria dos traders falha porque pensa
que trading é sobre comprar. Não é. É
sobre não cair em armadilhas.
No mercado de BTC, você está sendo
caçado por instituições.
Sem um escudo, suas emoções se tornam
seu pior inimigo.
Você sente o fomo. Clique em comprar e a
armadilha fecha. Trap defense BTC. Muda
tudo. Nosso motor visualiza as
armadilhas invisíveis das baleias.
Ensinamos a habilidade mais poderosa do
mundo, a disciplina de não fazer nada em
70% do tempo. Quando você finalmente se
move, move-se com 90% de certeza.
é defesa de alta resolução para um
mercado de alto risco. Não seja o trader
que perde tudo. Seja aquele que
permanece protegido.
Ative seu protocolo de defesa abaixo.
Bem-vindo à academia. M.